a famous sequence in mathematics has
each new number equal to the sum of the
previous two numbers
you may know this as the fibonacci
sequence
it was discovered more than a thousand
years before fibonacci by the
mathematician pingala in the analysis of
language
consider the words rice and om
they take longer to say than the words
thug and cot
in the sanskrit analysis of poetry
rice and ohm can be thought of as long
syllables that take two units of
metrical beat
thug and cot
would be considered short syllables that
take one unit of metrical beat
pingala wondered
how many ways are there to compose n
units of metrical beats using long and
short syllables
this is a mathematical problem of
combinatorics
if we have one total unit
we can only compose that by using one
short beat
so there's only one way that we can
compose one unit
if we had two units
we could compose it as two short beats
but we could also compose it as one long
syllable
there are two total ways we can compose
two units of metrical beat
what about three ways
now we can have three short syllables
we can start out with the short syllable
followed by a long syllable
or we could start off with the long
syllable and end with the short syllable
so there are three total ways to compose
three units of metrical beat
what about four units of metrical beat
what we could do is we can copy the
number of ways that we compose two units
of metrical beat and then we could put a
long syllable at the end
we can also copy the number of ways that
we make three units of metrical beat and
we can add a short syllable at the end
of each of these
in total there are five ways we can make
four units of metrical beat and this is
because five is equal to two plus three
and now we can see a pattern
if we want to compose n units of
metrical beat
we could end the line with the long
syllable which would leave n minus 2
units a metrical beat
and there are n minus 2 however many
number of ways to make that number of
beats
we can also end the line with a short
syllable
which would leave n minus 1 metrical
beats to be filled
so the number of ways to make n units of
metrical beat follows a recurrence
relation that is equal to the number of
ways to make n minus two plus the number
of ways to make n minus one
and it's really amazing that pingala
discovered this over a thousand years
before fibonacci
so we might more accurately call this
the pingala sequence
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel for free updates
when i post new videos on math and game
theory you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
also catch me at preshtalwalker on
social media
and please check out my books on math
and game theory i provided some links in
the video description
thanks for watching